as you could see I am broadcasting live
from the surface of the Sun because of
the brightness I don't know why it's so
bright actually it's raining outside so
I'm not sure why it looks like this
actually this is a it's a big moment
though this is my I believe this is my
100th episode so it's a huge milestone
not just in my own life but also I think
in the history of the world it's it's
it's a it's a huge moment and in
celebration
I will in celebration I will now issue
forth one celebratory honk of my horn
this is very exciting
ok are you ready for this it's a bit
it's this is huge
can't well I got ya cuz my car is off so
I can't the horn doesn't work because my
my cars this is very sad isn't it this
is pitiful my my one pathetic
celebration I can't even do because the
car is off it's it's it's a very set
Michael Knoll celebrated his 200th
episode recently and I think that you
know they they threw like a parade for
him and he rode on a golden chariot
attached to it to an elephant down the
street I believe and Here I am in my car
in the rain
with a broken horn
shouting into my webcam that's my
celebration it's let's just move past it
now I'd like to turn your attention to a
to a story
and I would read a little bit others to
you it's um this is in the hill the
headline is planned parenthood launches
largest ground game in its history it
says Planned Parenthood's political arm
is launching a massive effort to reach
millions of voters in order to unseat
Republicans at the state and federal
levels Kelly Robinson national
organizing director for Planned
Parenthood Federation America says
Planned Parenthood votes is launching
its largest ground game ever to turnout
voters and educate them about what's at
stake we'll knock on more doors and
reach more voters than ever before in a
midterm cycle Planned Parenthood and
Anna's partners say that it plans to
reach 4.5 million voters before Election
Day through advertising door-knocking
and other means this is this ground
campaign is in addition to the twenty
million dollar ad campaign that the
organization announced in March
the fact that Planned Parenthood is
spending tens of millions of dollars to
help Democrats get elected is that's
that's nothing new they've been doing
that for a very long time but there is
something different this time around
something is a little bit different
because actually the the Republican
Party is funding the effort
the Republican Party is funding the
effort to unseat themselves okay
just if you're wondering about how smart
the Republican Party is there you go the
Republican Party which I should remind
you has been in control of the
government for two years that Republican
Party is funding Planned Parenthood and
thus funding this effort to destroy them
but I you know more importantly they are
funding also an effort to destroy babies
the the government is continuing to hand
hundreds of millions of dollars a year
to a company that executes over 300
thousand babies a year I feel like I
should I should repeat that figure just
so just just for emphasis the Republican
part of the Planned Parenthood sorry I
get them confused now because they seem
very similar Planned Parenthood aborts
over three hundred thousand babies every
year and this is from they claim oh well
abortion is only three percent of what
we do which is a total lie but it's a
completely made-up statistic it's an
absolute total complete lie but it also
doesn't even matter because whatever
percentage of the overall thing it is
makes no difference the fact remains we
can look at the raw numbers and see they
kill 300,000 human beings a year
so the idea that I mean does anyone
would anyone look at Jeffrey Dahmer and
say and say well yeah I mean but serial
killing that was only like 5% of what he
did
I mean on a daily basis it was only
private 1% no we don't we don't look at
that we don't we don't we don't look at
the Nazi Party and say well the
Holocaust was only like 30 percent of
what they did overall let me think about
everything else they did I mean it was
really only because all that really
matters is the fact that they are
murdering people right but the
Republican Party as they are in charge
of the government and have not only not
only have they have they refrained from
cutting off this taxpayer pipeline to
this murderous organization they've
actually taken active measures to
prevent the severing of that pipeline
and for that reason it must be said that
the Republican Party is funding Planned
Parenthood the Republican Party is
taking money out of your pocket and
putting it into the blood-soaked hands
of baby killers this is not just a
democratic Nishat eveni more this is a
Republican initiative and this is you
know
this is more than just cowardice
the cowardice of the Republican Party
gets a lot of attention we all know that
the Republicans are a bunch of cowards
and so you know that that's true but
they're also idiots and I think that the
idiocy of the GOP should get its due as
well here
that the Republicans are funding the
Democrat Party while they fund abortions
because Planned Parenthood despite being
a tax a publicly subsidized organization
is somehow allowed to funnel millions of
dollars back into the coffers of
Democrat campaigns
so for in the past when it wouldn't have
been the Democrats in charge of this
with the Democrats which is a great deal
for the Democrats because what they
could do is they could take money from
you give it to Planned Parenthood and
then Planned Parenthood would wash it
and give it back to them a big great
deal right I mean I don't know I don't
see how it could possibly be legal but
it is a is a great deal the Republicans
had a chance to have had many chances to
put an end to this money laundering
operation but they chose not to
it's it's incredible well it's not
incredible that's what makes it
incredible what's incredible is that
it's not incredible it's incredible that
Republicans could be so inept so stupid
so spineless so gutless
so oblivious so clueless and yet they
could be all of those things to such a
degree unsurprisingly
now it is true that some Trump did
partially defund Planned Parenthood a
few months ago the by by changing a few
of the Health and Human Services rules
Planned Parenthood will now be deprived
of like fifty million dollars a year in
tax funding and that's fine that's good
nice but that's not even a drop in the
bucket because it still leaves half a
billion dollars a year that Planned
Parenthood will receive before it was
five hundred and fifty million now it's
just five hundred million dollars five
hundred million dollars of tax money a
year goes to Planned Parenthood
we gave Republicans total control of the
government and they have not even
managed to put a stop to this they
haven't even managed to put a stop to
the insanely unethical practice of
funding abortion conglomerates which
which should have been square one they
should have got that done in the first
week on the first day
you know if they really are a pro-life
organization think about it the
Republicans they claim to be pro-life
Pro small government and pro financial
responsibility well they would only need
to be one of those things to defund
Planned Parenthood if they were just one
of them they would have gotten it done
in the first week yet they claim to be
all three of those things they claim
that those three things are their
guiding principles and yet they have
provided us no evidence whatsoever to to
prove that by the way let me just
address one thing briefly here because
this is what's always said any time we
talked about Planned Parenthood funding
you know or funding Planned Parenthood
the defenders of the of the baby killers
will argue that well you know taxpayers
aren't actually funding abortions and
they're not really funding the political
campaigns because the tax money doesn't
go towards those things you see
um that's the arc and that argument is
about as credible as the well it's only
three percent of what they do
okay think it's but both of those
arguments are not only false but
irrelevant that even if they were true
it wouldn't make a difference but
they're not true and the thing is to
even to even begin to accept that
argument
we'd have to trust Planned Parenthood
okay because Planned Parenthood they're
the ones telling us that they're not
using any of this money for these other
things can we trust them no because
Planned Parenthood is run by filthy
disgusting hideous liars and we can't
trust anything they say and certainly
any attempts to regulate them or
investigate them or check up on them
those are always rebuffed abortion is
the least regulated industry since
slavery so it's hard to know if anything
they say is true but in any case it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter because
money is fungible
so if I'm doing two things a and B and
you give me money for a but not for B
you've obviously financed both
okay because the original money that I
had before you help me out that would
have been split between the two but now
that can all that money can go entirely
to be because you've taken care of a
that's that's what it means for money to
be fungible I'll show you what I mean
okay let's say that um just by way by
way of example let's say that that that
I want to go on an expedition to
Antarctica to Club baby seals to death
let's say that's and that's the main
thing I want to do down there is I just
want to go to an article Antarctica find
a bunch of baby seals and beat them to
death that's what I want to do okay but
let's also say that while I'm there I'm
gonna feed penguins as well you know
I'll do that also you know now let's say
that I only have a certain amount of
money to spend on this humanitarian
mission I don't have enough money to do
both things
right now I can't I can't find answer as
it stands I cannot finance both the seal
clubbing and the penguin feeding then
let's say that you come by and you
announce plans to give me a large sum of
cash but only for the penguin feeding
because you very much disapprove of the
seal clubbing
now thanks to you all of my own supply
of money can go towards beating baby
seals to death since you're taking care
of the other half so so even though you
made this even though you gave me all
this money and you said now that I don't
want to I don't want one penny of that
to go towards beating seals
now I know I'm giving money to someone
who's gonna go I'm giving money to a
person who's gonna go beat baby's heels
but you better not may use any of that
of that money for effort for that do it
for you use this money for the other
thing even though I said that or even
though you said that you still have
funded both things now of course that's
ridiculous though because you would
never give me money for a trip to
Antarctica if you knew that I'd be
spending a large portion a large portion
of my trip murdering baby seals
and if you refused to give me any money
and and then I said well you must hate
penguins then the Penguins are gonna
starve you're telling me you don't want
to fund the feeding of penguins what's
wrong with you well then you would
simply point out that there are many
other ways to support the penguin
population without funding an expedition
whose primary purpose is to murder baby
seals that's what you would say
you
but the economics here are still the
same if you give me money for one you
give me money for both
so just like if you if you you know it's
if you pee in one side of the pool you
have peed in both sides of the pool
because that's how it that's how water
works and that's how money works so we
are financing abortions we're financing
a lot of them that's the reality your
tax money goes towards killing children
it's that simple
there's no way around
so anyone who defends the subsidizing of
Planned Parenthood they should at least
defend it honestly
and so our money not only goes towards
killing children but it also goes
towards funding the Democrat Party
which means that the Republican Party is
is is not only subsidizing the killing
of children but they are subsidizing the
political campaigns of their opponents
which means that the Republican Party's
continued funding of the abortion
industry is the greatest act of not only
political cowardice and betrayal but the
greatest act of political stupidity that
I think we've ever seen in our lifetimes
but what else can you really expect from
such a collection of empty suits liars
and pushovers which is what the
Republican Party is and I'll leave it
there thanks everybody for watching
thanks for listening Godspeed